viewers have been asking for more
caption contests both the videos
themselves in which i put together the
top
10 my totally subjective top 10
of the captions that people put on
photos in my youtube channel
and they also want the opportunity to
participate
in it so i did another caption contest
this month and i picked this photo which
i'm i'm particularly a fan of it shows
our old dog amica who we unfortunately
had to put down
almost a year ago and she had chewed up
a tennis ball
uh pretty good so that there was a big
crack in it and every once in a while i
would stick it on my nose sort of like a
clown nose
but with a tennis ball and then you know
she would
sometimes get angry and bite it off or
she would get
a little bit exasperated and you see her
here looking
at my my wife took the picture and
sort of saying what the hell is this
crap so
there are quite a few good captions i
picked out the top ten
and with no further ado here they are
uh here's one of my favorite ones from
kevin beck i love seeing philosophical
types being
silly indeed we all put our pants on by
the proverbial one leg at a time you
know
philosophers aren't not ordinary people
you know we we live a life like
everybody else and i think sometimes
people lose sight of that because of the
seriousness of so much of philosophy
here's another good one by issel bell
exasperated by her master's failure to
understand the essential nature of a
tennis ball for fetch
amica finally broke the fourth wall to
ask if any dog can truly be said to be a
good girl
then she bit him on the nose and that
yeah i think if you've been watching a
lot of my videos
you know that i sometimes use as an
example of
our rational nature versus the
non-rational nature of animals the fact
that they don't
question about themselves they they can
be a good
dog or be a bad dog but they don't they
don't actually ask themselves that
question
and i don't think they they worry too
much about the essential nature of a
tennis ball but they definitely think
that it has certain roles
and the role is not to be on my nose at
least for
amica here's another one uh by
eagle ray flyby i'm used to thrashing at
mauling and destroying that ball
but something's telling me i might have
to consider an alternative option
right now he's putting these in you know
like in amica's head
thinking about uh you know the
the need to figure out another function
for the ball so those two are kind of
similar to each other
here's another one from austin tillman
when you get a half price nose job from
some back alley doctor in tijuana but
decided to take the opportunity to teach
the doggo about rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer yeah except in this case it
would be the green nose
reindeer and that would indeed be
quite a quite a nose job if anyone were
to get it
now we get into the ones that are a
little bit more philosophical retro
gamer
i'm not telling you where he's got a
frisbee in a socratic alenkus
alankus of course is is sort of the
refutation that socrates
engaged in so the joke it kind of makes
sense it kind of doesn't make sense
but that's okay because it's jokes
anyway and then we get another one
that is playing off of obviously
descartes
right amica can't believe what she's
seeing but
at least if she's doubting she must
exist
um i don't you know she's not doubting
her own existence but she is definitely
wondering what is going on and you know
we can remember too that that philosophy
begins in wonder and it doesn't always
have to be
wonder about the universe or you know
free will versus determinism sometimes
it can just be
like you know the proverbial what in the
hell
is going on here so if a dog could
philosophize maybe this would be
an occasion of this then we get another
one here
and here this is from ty's monk if we
see
a live demonstration of what camus
possibly meant when he wrote about
the absurd uh the joke there of course
is that there's a
you know myriad types of absurdity
this certainly does qualify i think as
an
instance where the absurd could
come into prominence for us and we could
have the feeling
of the absurd then we get two about
hegel
nick says that moment when you lose your
mind from seven years of teaching hegel
now of course i've been teaching hegel
almost three times that long so
if i was gonna lose my mind after seven
years of hegel
i would have lost it three times at this
point
and then uh here's another one this is
from
jeff sullivan look girl you thought you
were gonna have to choose between me and
the tennis ball lucky for you i've been
reading hegel
this is synthesis you know the sin means
and then
that that that you know coming together
i don't think there's any way that you
can look at this
as being something like a hegelian
synthesis
but i would be open to being persuaded
and then finally we have uh guttergrown
has this nice
quip from diogenes the cynic which as
all of you know
that means hound diogenes the hound
member of that that school kunos means
means a dog or hound
and and it was also used for the
designation of them
dogs and philosophers do the greatest
good
and get the fewest rewards
i don't i don't know about that it's a
great line
uh i can certainly think of those who
get the short end of the stick even more
than dogs
and philosophers but yeah it's a good
it's a good quip so these are the
the roundup of what i thought were the
best
uh captions and you can stay tuned
for further ones coming out in in
subsequent months that you can
jump in on and say your best lines
and you might see them in another
caption contest video like this one
you